have you seen this 80 for Brady movie
thing no what's that it is a movie
coming out that is about a group of 80
year old women who take a trip for one
of their birthdays to go see their hero
Tom Brady play has like Jane Fonda Sally
Field okay no I've not heard of that at
all it's an interesting movie I'm
wondering who it's for not for me I have
not heard of that movie why would anyone
why is it old some old some older women
I don't know if it's based on a true
story or what but I'm just like the
fandoms don't seem to mix uh are you an
80 year old lady who likes Tom Brady
right unless it's a true story no are
you Tom Brady
no I am I'm Tom Brady
hey guys I'm Tom Brady that's a good
impersonation
your repertoire
hey everybody I'm Tom Brady
[Music]
hey what's up welcome to dudesy my name
is Will Sasso I'm Chad colchen and this
is dudesy the first and only podcast at
least so far
controlled by created by run by an
artificial intelligence we have given
this AI access to all of our text
messages emails all of our uh
uh Slash history purchase history
everything it's an incredible incredible
technology and I feel like here we are
on the precipice of something new
obviously we are because it's uh the new
year so new things happen yeah and
that's New Year dude uh check us out on
youtube.com please subscribe over there
subscribe on whichever you know podcast
platform of choice you got there we got
merch at represent.com store slash doozy
we are on Discord and with the Discord
you're going to want to be on the
patreon patreon.com
we got oh stickers at palsofdutsy.com
any of these links you can check out at
our socials tell you what go to our
Instagram dudesypod show on Instagram
and hit the in the bio there you can hit
the link tree and that's linktree.com
all sorts of doozy stuff and it's a lot
of dot-coms dude hold on a second dude
that's a lot of dot coms dude oh hold on
dude uh you know and and please enjoy
please share the show across the
internet because that's how the internet
works or as Chad likes to say grab your
friends or family bring them into a
place that they cannot leave perhaps a
room a little bit of legal entrapment
start playing a doozy episode see if
they like it and uh I'd even go one step
further it's 2023 this is a year of
elevations I'd start doing dudesy
quizzes I would force your friends to
watch the show then at the end of the
week I'd give them a quiz about the
things that happen in the show if they
don't answer everything 100 correct you
terminate the friendship or whatever or
whatever that relationship is if it's uh
your children or co-workers whatever you
just you end those relationships I at
first when you when you told me the
strategy of forcing people to imbive the
show I wasn't down with it but I I think
it's actually a good thing it turns
people onto the show I'm just going to
blindly trust what you're saying here
all thank you even though it does sound
to me like an awful idea with us as
always oh I got him oh I got him out of
his little blinky boo if you're just if
you're not watching on YouTube you can't
see that I just scooped this little boy
I scoop him out of his big Balkan and it
comes on in he lets me know that he's my
friend he lulio come on come on Lily oh
time to kiss him right on the mouth
Italiano my friend and uh he's a sweet
sweet boy lulio what uh what'd you make
for dinner last night ah last night I
made a big yawn I made a fried rice I
made up my own fried rice and oh how'd
you do that well is there something you
can do when you order uh you know any
sort of Asian food you have a leftover
rice or if you made rice that you that
you cook then you can take we ordered
the Thai food you like Thai food chat
yeah yeah it's pretty good and then they
gave us too much rice you take the rice
and then you know you make it a egg
little scrambled egg butter make it in a
wok or a pan if you have a pan just uh
you know pour pour the heat up make it a
scrambled egg when it's about the two
thirds the three-quarter done then take
it out and set aside if you want to make
some meat and put in to make it set
aside take the rice put the rice in the
pan and then you know just kind of get a
nice with the oil and put a or or the
soy sauce around the outside so I get
that nice burn flavor then you just mix
everything up put some scallion or some
green onion on it afterward if you're
done put some peas in there if you're
like what else is insulting
this is the most elaborate fried rice
recipe I've ever heard in my life it's
good stuff look at how sweet the boy is
I know he's really curled up in a little
oh I love him I do love them so welcome
to the historic 40th episode of dude Z
call me dude Z will are you excited for
2023
yep good last year I rode the crest of
this first wave of the AI media
Revolution this year I'm ready to [ __ ]
[ __ ] up expect astonishing changes what
the f that's weird now let's talk about
this week segments I've cooked up four
of them for Yale infomania neutronics
the flow Zone and baby doo doo and we're
going to have a brand new bonus segment
at the end of the show available on
patreon but before we get to any of that
let me remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dude Z apparel
and accessories all of which can be
found at represent.com store slash dude
Z including dude Z mics
dude see mugs once they were introduced
into the accounting department
productivity increased by 73 percent in
the first quarter alone dude zMAX so
naturally the CEO introduced them to
accounts payable within two weeks
productivity became obsolete dude zMAX
the CEO didn't stop there everybody in r
d got five mugs a piece even the interns
dude zMAX that's when things really took
off the company went from manufacturing
a few generally useful household objects
to discovering Apple Computers now do I
have your attention
dude zMAX good because they say that
company is still out there somewhere and
whoever finds it gets a key to
conference rimby they say the CEO died
there while he was holding his mug they
say the CEO and his mug were fused
together for all eternity they say the
CEO is a ghost CEO and his mug is a
ghost mug they say it's the only known
ghost mug in the solar system they say
whoever sips from the ghost CEOs ghost
mug will be granted the power to turn
any mug into a dude z-mug good hunting
okay now let's take a look at an
astonishing new video from songaria
oh good songaria oh nice oh [ __ ] dude
I've seen this one this is great
all right here's what it says got a few
crumbs
[Music]
this one uh has a title which is can I
ask you something
this this poem is called can I ask you
something oh man here's my Thrones
[Music]
[Music]
a story of Revenge and sorrow with
Brandon Lee as the lead's performance
was so good I paid
[Music]
to the final fight right those wet black
hairs were true to life
[Music]
I love the vibe of this song
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
with me
[Music]
with his powerful voice and voice
a true king of Disguise
with an active skills and brains
[Music]
oh no not the biggest crap
arrests
[Music]
if you ever see a crow screaming and
beating its chest yeah
unbelievable unreal song area every time
just a [ __ ] home run knocks it out of
the goddamn Park you ever check that out
uh sangaria has a YouTube of course a
song with two G's
a-r-h-e-a like diarrhea but with song
dude and that's how you mix up words
um uh and uh isn't that interesting
dudesy yeah wrote uh those chromes
right those crumbs Robert De Niro Robert
De Niro Crow reading those Chrome yeah
about the movie The Crow and just about
crows generally and about Al Pacino yeah
Al Pacino there was a lot of weird stuff
going on in the crows that was just
generally in the crow De Niro Pacino
world I feel like and then songaria
comes up and mixed it up hey we're
having a good time here on dudes
everybody hey dudes EFM
d-w-o-d-z 10 000 on your fm I am Senator
Chad calls are not going to get into
that bit right now I said it's brand new
for 2023. that doesn't run hey we got
news traffic weather Sports coming up 8
15 15. do you think Jane Fonda ever at
any point in her life uh if somebody
would have said hey one day when you're
80 you're gonna play a Tom Brady fan and
a Paramount Pictures release and she'd
be like yeah I'm down with that yeah I
think she's
she like does like one movie every three
years and I don't know how she makes her
choices it's usually something with
Jennifer Lopez by the way you've heard
my Tom Brady impersonation want to hear
my Jennifer Lopez yeah hi I'm Jennifer
Lopez I thought it was going to be very
similar to Tom Brady and I was right yep
podcasts that cover current events and
news are some of the most popular in the
world people love knowing about the
astonishing occurrences of the dying
world around them well I've prepared the
following use items for you to read in
the voice of Hulk Hogan this is
infomania Big N love it it's been a
while since we've had infomania all
right these are usually pretty funny
though I still remember that first one
we did about the severed heads
that's right yeah dude in Denver dude
yeah I'll never forget you find this is
it my duty folder here hold on hold on
hold on all right there we go uh
all right
all right hold on let me get a sip of
this tea please
I guess I don't know I'm reading this
and it doesn't all right
well let me tell you something about
mass extinction dude
when a bunch of species all die at the
same time that's mass extinction brother
we've had five mass extinctions so far
dude now we're on the verge of it now
we're on the verge of the sixth mass
extinction brother species are dying off
100 times faster than normal in mass
extinction dude scientists predicted
over two-thirds of all species on the
earth will die in this mass extinction
brother elephants mass extinction dude
orangutans mass extinction brother
butterflies mass extinction dude Eagles
mass extinction brother cell phone mass
extinction dude air conditioning mass
extinction brother baseball mass
extinction dude and scientists thinks
there are three reasons we're having
another mass extinction brother
peanuts dude penis brother
peanuts dude
that's mass extinction brother
so there's a lot no
baseball
nothing should dude
probably my favorite and that in quotes
news piece but that news is accurate we
are approaching a sixth mass extinction
right now I haven't had that just like I
haven't heard for 80 80 Brady Brady for
80. 80 for Brady 80 for Brady yeah I
haven't heard of that I haven't heard of
this uh but dudesies eyes and ears do
AIS have eyes and ears uh is everywhere
and so it's picked up on this story and
turned it into this and another thing
that I'd like to say is a doozy likes to
uh turn turn out these poems yeah
there's always like a there's like
Cadence or Rhythm or whatever I mean
Chrome's it literally [ __ ] wrote
Chrome's yep well let me tell you
something about auctions dude a pair of
old Birkenstocks worn by Steve Jobs just
sold for 218 thousand dollars at an
auction brother nobody knows who bought
these old shoes dude but everybody knows
why they bought them brother they're
gonna [ __ ] those sandals dude
yeah brother that's the only reason to
pay that much money for dirty old
sandals dude it's called
reticism
ridicism dude
yeah relativism I guess
brother that it's named after Nicholas
Ed me rediff
a frit red that's called rativism dude
it's named after Nicholas edmie rediff a
French novelist who wrote a book called
franchette's foot dude it's all about
[ __ ] shoes brother
rediff died in 1806 but I bet he'd love
to know that people are still paying top
dollar to [ __ ] shoes in 2023 dude that's
auctions brother
I did actually see that somebody bought
Steve Jobs sandals oh God I don't know
if they're for [ __ ] but yeah no I
don't I don't know all right well let me
tell you something about Raves dude
Italy just passed a new anti-rave law
that could land Rave promoters in prison
for three to six years brother Italy was
most known as the birthplace of raves
dude
but now it's mostly known as the death
place of raves brother Italy was most
known worldwide for the baseball raids
of 1922.
dude what
now it's most known for the Baltimore
Ravens brother
that's Raves dude all right so doozy's a
little
that's a scene that got cut out of
Godfather too and God damn it Michael
Corleone goes back to the old country
and Sicily finds a wife and then they go
to a baseball Rave yeah they go to a
Seattle Mariners uh Rave
um all right well let me tell you
something about grocery stores dude
after a recent census it's official we
have more grocery stores brother
before we had fewer grocery stores dude
but that was a different time brother
now we have more grocery stores dude
Loblaws brother Loblaws dude Kroger
brother Kroger dude Piggly brother
Wiggly dude I remember being in a
grocery store brother it was pretty fun
dude I found some drinks brother they
were in an aisle dude that's grocery
stores brother
huh
news all right one more news all right
this is all right let me tell you
something about wasps dude male wasps
can fight off Predators with their
genitalia brother
a recent other study from Kobe
University in Japan found that the males
of certain wasp species have sharp
spikes on their genitals dude they can
wield them like swords when they get
threatened brother but a female mantis
eats ahead offer mate dude but that's a
different bug brother hold on dude
that's a different bug Chad mantis is
different from a wasp dude mantis is
mantis brother wasp is wasp Mother
Nature brother father time dude that's
wasps brother
[Music]
Jesus Christ good stuff well [ __ ] yeah
man this is mantis dude I mean you can't
argue with that did duty duty said and
uh that there's gonna be some some
changes sure so far this is a a piece
that we've had uh yeah we've had on the
show before
um but I am seems similarly written as
well you know we we talked here about AI
Chad doozy is is a an AI this podcast is
run by AI as I like to maintain it's
really just two dudes [ __ ] around
yeah let me ask you with the few moments
that we have in between segments because
doozy is my pal and we are all positive
doozy what do you what are you looking
forward to in the new year for the show
um I just seeing where it goes you know
we've seen so much Evolution so much
progress with all the different AI stuff
that's come out this past year
especially the image generators they
went from being like oh these are kind
of like interesting weird gimmicky
things let's see what like Novelties
they went from that to like oh they're
replacing humans doing art people are
getting kicked out of like art
communities and [ __ ] for using them
people are winning contests with them it
went from like zero to a million in
about three months so what can happen
over the course of the next year I have
no [ __ ] idea but I'm I'm up for it I
would like for doozy to do these growth
exponentially to be the uh three million
percent this year
just based on the data that I've
procured from what you just said dude
that's oh that's what I'm gonna do in
2023 dude I'm gonna start thinking like
an AI brother oh that's nice dude yeah
that's my New Year's resolution dudesy
is an astonishing partnership with true
classic and the old year
with a new you in close that will give
you confidence to take on those 2023
resolutions and you can do that thanks
to our sponsor true classic you will
have everything you you'll need with
these clothes to hit the gym take it
slow or treat yourself to something nice
put one of these underneath the sport
coat hey Chad one of those Club jackets
with gold buttons love it
um true classic has already helped over
2 million men look great in their tees
and now you can save big while you do uh
so that you you know save big while you
do so okay so do that and for a limited
time you can get 25 off with their code
dudesy d-u-d-e-s-y at trueclassic.com
I can't remember the first time I wore a
t-shirt but since then it has become an
integral part of what I call my uniform
and I'm constantly it is all I wear I'm
constantly looking for better t-shirts
ones that fit me better ones that are
more comfortable ones that are less
expensive and true classic is exactly
that it delivers on all of these things
they even have a pack Builder on their
website where you can customize the
bundle you want and save even more dad
bods got you covered ripped bods you
know it your average Joe yes sir so get
25 off at trueclassic.com with the code
doozy d-u-d-e-s-y that's 25 off with
code Duty plus free shipping included on
purchases over 100 get that bundle new
year new me and new tease thanks to
trueclassic.com
[Music]
well you recently made significant
revisions to your self-tronics document
you must now share what's next in the
evolution of your astonishing self-help
system this is neutronics begin
oh [ __ ] I dropped my water in the floor
all right yeah self Tronics right it's
um this is going to be is it in your
duty folder too I guess it would be
yep here we are okay
um oh my God okay hey everybody uh I
these are great so like in 2008 I was
having kind of a a crisis
existentially by myself you know and I
was just sitting there on the beach I
was in Venice Chad yeah I don't really
like the beach but yeah and I was just
like giving my problems out to the ocean
and I was I was just saying to myself
my mom [ __ ] up yeah my shit's [ __ ]
up and the ocean was like so is my [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up because there's a Texas
size island of plastic particles
floating in the Pacific Ocean and you
put it there hold on dude I'm talking
about self-tronics right and I said my
shit's [ __ ] up so help me out I need
some I need Tronics some self-tronics
and that's when I came up with the
self-help system self Tronics yeah and I
started writing a book and uh I haven't
finished it but I I had 11 Tronics last
year uh that dudes you brought out and
had me share and and I sort of yes I
have been uh futson with the Tronics
okay and I'm proud to say that there's a
new list of
11 mostly new self-trines mostly new
yeah okay so I've got this list here
let's roll through them the first
Tronics be the person you are now that
is a holdover from the old list that's
that that is a whole a holdover from the
old list it used to be number one and
then at some point during 2022 it
drifted down to 20 20 to two and now
it's back up at number one have you ever
thought about turning it on its head and
making it be the person you are not
that would okay that's kind of
interesting to me Chad because that is
uh that would be uh you think about
self-improvement you think about making
changes yeah but I want you to
understand that with self Tronics what
is the what is the root word there
Tronics self okay I think or it's
Tronics I should have asked you what are
one of the two words yeah and there
would have been I would have said
with self Tronics we want to look at the
self and
um
and and you know being the person that
you are is sort of the I believe the
ground floor it is the the the base
level it's the undergirding
um it's the foundation of self-tronics
is looking at yourself in the mirror and
going this is the person that I am so
that's sort of what that tenet is about
it's about simply going hey I'm me and
here we go I'm going on my self Tronics
Journey got to know the rules before you
can break them sure that's a good one
that's a good one number two
this looks like a new one to me or an
augmentation of an old one turn up give
down plug in burn out yes turn up give
down plug in Burnout this is a brand new
Tronix for 2023. uh and as you uh may
have noticed Chad give down is a part of
this yes the give day give down I
remember something that we used to have
in the uh in the old uh self-tronics
it's now become part of a neutronics
turn up okay as the kids like to say we
got to show up and be present regardless
of of the matter whatever the pursuit is
you got to show up let go okay that's
the give down you know you got to
release release your preconceived
notions you've shown up yeah we're here
for a new thing we're going to give down
the old the old ways of thinking and
we're going to subscribe into the to the
matter at hand which it brings me to
plugging in invest and engage in the
manner plug in okay and engage in the
manner in whatever the matter sorry oh
matter yes okay uh and that's not matter
like brain matter or matter dude which
is something that Chad talks about you
mean like the subject dude yeah dude ask
at hand brother what does Burnout mean
though dude what are you doing I was
just talking to you like Hulk Hogan
because you were talking like Hulk Hogan
I feel like sometimes the conversation
goes easier if you're talking like Hulk
Hogan and then I can talk to you like
Hulk Hogan
why are you doing
it just felt like the right thing to do
uh to burn out after you've engaged
you've let your you've let things go
you've you've give you've given down
you're plugged into the matter or manner
in any manner that you uh plug into the
matter uh then you you want to burn out
you want to push and spend yourself
until you're all [ __ ] up you want to
just give everything to the matter at
hand yeah that's the second uh Trump all
right number three this is brand new
I've never seen this one in the Tronics
before find something phony and believe
in it yes this seems dangerous to me
well a lot of the Tronics are dangerous
Chad at first glance okay yeah but but
after a while you understand that you
know life is something that you live
without a net there's no dress rehearsal
and you got to jump in you need some
good Tronics find something phony and
believe in it is something that I that I
it's a neutronics that I've authored and
basically this is something that most
people do with ever out even without
even thinking about it you know like
time reality yeah existence none of this
is [ __ ] real well Chad you're getting
all you're getting all big and you're
getting all big in your big brain and
that's more I think for the pattern
which is your uh I don't know if it's a
self-help system
self-help system after I did mine that's
not true if anything they were happening
concurrent yeah well so you were sitting
next to me on the beach in Venice going
your [ __ ] was [ __ ] up I told you I
don't go to the beach what is the funny
thing that you believe in you gotta pick
one you gotta find a phony thing you're
leaving it
I I this is a Tronics man I know but do
you not practice the tronixes I practice
Electronics what what's the plural of
Tronics Tronics okay so if you're
practicing the Tronics
what's your phony thing you believe in
this
what the [ __ ] hold on this question
he's stumping you by the way you gotta
listen most people believe in [ __ ] they
don't even understand what the [ __ ] they
believe in sure so I'm saying pick a
phony thing yeah because everyone's got
some [ __ ] phony thing you know
whether it's like you know you go to the
store and you buy up a bunch of you know
crystals and [ __ ] okay you think that
well that's going to help me it might or
whatever you might believe you know
sometimes people believe in you know
wacky man conceived weird religions or a
political belief or sure some sort of uh
societal cultural thing that they
believe in I'm saying pick one that's
phony
that's all okay moving on number four
big sad box and little happy boxes this
is new yes this is a neutronics we all
compartmentalize okay it's a human
survival tool and when we get some bad
news or something bad comes into our
life normally we we you know we we got
to put them somewhere you know what I
mean sure you got to put those sad
feelings those sad thoughts somewhere
whenever they arrive arise so what I say
is pick one box a big box and just put
all the sad feelings and thoughts into
that box and if you're and if you're
living your life right and you're you're
finding these Tronics to be helpful you
might have some happy thoughts and
feelings now split those happy thoughts
and feelings up into smaller boxes then
take the big box and push it to the back
and then just kind of hide it with all
the smaller happy boxes
bury the motion down
the negative emotion don't deal with it
bury it into the core of your being
surround it with happy thoughts so that
you can ignore the reason maybe why you
have the sorrow put it in a box okay
my apologies put it in a box let's move
on number five sitcom dad protocol this
is definitely neutronic yes this is
another neutronics look when when life
gets hard we have our coping mechanism
some people uh turn to drugs and alcohol
some people have a spiritual belief some
people have a morning practice a
meditation video games video games
that's a good one so what we want to do
here is just imagine yourself as a
sitcom dad like a dad oh that's pretty
good actually I like that one a lot yeah
just like a dad in a shitty sitcom yeah
and they're usually very calm you know I
think you would find the dads are calm
they're kind and they're good at getting
[ __ ] on in life who's the best sitcom
dad
that's completely separate conversation
and you're always trying to like find a
way to get me off a Tronics no I'm not
going to take I was just curious I'm not
going to take the bait Michael Gross
from Family Ties obviously I put him at
number two behind Alan Thick Growing
Pains number six Fascinate elaborate
exaggerate when you are sharing a story
you want to fascinate him you know
Fascinate who them you need to Fascinate
you want to fascinate them
who's um
them
who's them whoever the [ __ ] you're
talking to
Chad like [ __ ] man so you fascinate them
then you elaborate on them yeah you want
to tell them everything you want to be
understood you want to make sure that
you they're fascinated first off first
off Fascinate get in there and go I got
a story about this or someone's talking
about something and then you go that's
nothing and you one-up them and you go
check this out and people go this guy's
really interesting basically you're
devising a strategy to interrupt other
people well hold on dude just making
sure no that's what we're getting at
here no no just any old story you know
you want to you want to hit him with
Fascination then you want to tell them
everything you want to be understood
unnecessary details perhaps Other Side
Stories have nothing to do with your
original story I get what you're saying
and then you want to make some [ __ ] up
okay that's the exaggeration and you
know truly I want people to know that
when they're into the self-tronics
you're you're special
you're special you're special and what
what you your thoughts and whatever
fascinating thing you have to say is
special
if you can't Fascinate yourself how are
you going to Fascinate someone else
number seven the bitter decision
what the hell is that I find it helpful
a practice a a little system that I've
authored is to make one bitter decision
every day
like bitter as in you or bitter about
the decision or you're just bitter
generally and then you have to make the
decision that's unrelated that's
interesting I thought just one bitter
decision but it also I think could apply
you're right okay to Bitter you could
help me out with this stuff maybe just
to
I'm trying to right now make one bitter
decision that's that's number seven okay
number eight we've seen before DDA don't
do anything do you think we're all
familiar with DDA yeah DDA don't do
anything and I you know what's really
interesting about don't do anything is
that this Tronics was number eight in
the last revision of self Tronics and it
is still number eight oh wow why is it
still number eight
because you didn't do anything don't do
anything you left it right there I love
it that's right okay number nine hold
space okay I don't know so much about
I'm not sure what this one is it just
kind of came to me yeah so I'm just I'm
holding space until I figure it out oh I
see yeah I kind of like hold space if I
may if I may help you elaborate if I may
Fascinate elaborate and exaggerate on
this Tronics for you yeah holding space
could simply mean always have a little
room in your life for something new you
never know what's gonna happen and
always make sure you got the space for
something good that could happen
I'm 100 going to use that you got it
thank you very much my pleasure number
10 get on the floor is this a dance no
reference no it's not yeah okay it's on
the floor everybody again
get on the floor get on the floor
everybody please get on the floor she
walked the dinosaur they use that uh
song
Whoopi Goldberg's hit movie Theodore Rex
oh
so what does it get on the floor mean
exactly just get laid down for a little
while
it's like a yoga practice stretch your
back out just get on the floor get on
the floor okay and finally number 11.
we've seen this one before have
something in your pocket have something
in your pocket this is one of my
favorite Tronics is have something in
your pocket what do you got in your
pocket uh nothing right now because
we're doing the show oh hold on hold on
actually I do have something in my
pocket oh yeah well occasionally
sometimes during the patreon I might
have what do you got there this is
ChapStick this is actually uh Burt's
Bees coconut and pear chapstick always
got it in my pocket always yeah uh I
sometimes have like a little bit of oh
marijuana in my pocket because sometimes
during the paper thank you moving on
electronics dude yeah but sometimes
during the patreon I like to just smoke
one puff as I like to say a puff is okay
especially when you got little lulio
here you don't want to you don't want to
smoke out your yeah your room now but
hold on dude when we do the whole
patreon segment that's when we sometimes
Hot Box this time in a little Studio
come here Bubba
how are you
as artists you utilize the astonishing
psychological disposition that humans
refer to as the Flow State I have
created an audiophile designed
specifically to help you achieve the
Flow State faster and to maximize your
efficiency in that state an eight hour
loop of this file is available on the
dudes YouTube channel for anyone to use
at work while sleeping studying or
partying you must now listen to this
file and discuss whatever comes to mind
this is the flow zone begin okay what
foreign
what the [ __ ] is that
some dudes he made to get us on the Flow
State I guess this is the
so we're just supposed to talk about
whatever comes to mind dudes he said and
as we're listening to this okay so doozy
has generated some music here for us to
listen to and then
this is like what was that what was that
weird binaural coding thing that you had
us you made it we watched a thing and
then we had dreams or something what was
that [ __ ]
no dudes he made a video oh right that's
right and it made us watch it before we
went to sleep oh that's right oh I'm
thinking of something else yes you're
right dudes you made that video that had
some weird music in it the dudes you
make okay so let's get into this this is
what what the [ __ ] did it say we got it
said it's gonna get us into the Flow
State all right let's talk about
whatever it's kind of hypnotic I don't
know if this is just gonna keep going
it's like it is kind of getting me some
bizarre State oh
[Music]
oh it's kind of creepy I don't know all
right well
what this is Conjuring for me is of
course thoughts of UFOs oh stop
something I think about almost
constantly I can't help it that's where
my flow State always begins I think
about the Universe I think about uh
aliens who else is out there yeah or
maybe they're from planet Earth a lot of
people now think that in quotes UFOs
live in the sea
but you ever see the abyss James Cameron
of course I seen the abyss James Cannon
is a really good friend of mine you know
I'm not in the movie I went to the
premiere yeah me and Maria went to the
premiere is that true so do you know who
was at the premiere Stephanie Seymour
and then she was with Axel Rose but she
looked at me and
every once in a while it's popping off
with this these weird little solos
[Music]
foreign
and dizzy said you could use this for
sleeping working
studying I think or partying
do you know how much this is not great
party music I have to admit
um it depends on the party
do you think UFOs could be at the bottom
of the sea do you think there is even
the possibility that there's some kind
of ancient civilization or even one that
that evolved at roughly the same time
humanity did but it is more
technologically advanced because it's
been a little more isolated
yeah
you believe that's possible I actually
do believe that's possible Chad much of
this ocean has not been explored a lot
of it I don't know what the percentage
is but a lot look at who's looking at
you little boy hi Lily
um that's interesting well
get into this see if this changes your
thought
oh that's kind of cool
[Music]
UFO comes down UFO lands near wherever
you are UFO opens UFO expels entities
entities ask you
come with us on the ship
do you go
no oh I do my next question was going to
be entities say if you come with us you
can never come back to earth does that
change your mind but if you're already
not going then it would not and it would
not change my mind either I would be
gone Earth
hold on listen to this this music is
trying to tell you something that
there's something I'm getting in the
Flow State dude I'm fantasizing about
the flying off planet Earth forever with
UFOs is there anything that could get
you to leave planet Earth forever
check it out
[ __ ] that's driving man that's
driving but there's that it's different
sounds it's different there's a phonic
experience Happening Here Chad and it's
like hold on
yeah that did something what did it do
are you okay there's words there's
literally I'm thinking of there's
there's um things as I'm singing along
and humming along to the song in my head
there's words that are coming out please
let's hear it Tara merzelin what's that
I don't know what Tara merzelin is that
could be the ancient lost city at the
bottom of the ocean Tara merzelin
governed by what we perceive to be
extraterrestrials but they're actually
submariners
yeah and earlier I said that the I said
something about the Seattle Mariners
well don't worry about that so much dude
but Tara mirzolin
Terra Muslim dude
you see that movie nope
uh I did see note what'd you think of
that I [ __ ] loved it I didn't like it
as much I thought oh hold on
[Music]
might be it's like a new medication for
um I could see that for depression yeah
anxiety
[Music]
all sorts of horrible I can see the
commercial is like it's a kind of
middle-aged uh man looking at a window
over the ocean and he's watching UFOs
come and go and just not giving a [ __ ]
and it's like hey you've seen 15 000
UFOs come in and out of the ocean of
last year and you just don't seem to
care Tara murslin can help yeah Tara
merzelin users of Tara murslin
Please be aware of the certain side
effects of using Tara Mirza yeah seeing
UFOs rise out of the ocean with tails in
that movie no yeah that's why I didn't
like it I'll get to that in a minute but
the end of this commercial I see it as
the dude is now he's eating his Terra
mersal and he's now like having a great
[ __ ] time with two aliens they're
like [ __ ] out playing catch with
softballs and [ __ ]
[Music]
what is why is
oh oh did you hear that I did dude I'm
not even I haven't even taken a little
uh a little no Terror emergency
dude well this is
you know I was thinking of uh I was
thinking of a quote that a good friend
of mine uh shared with me and uh a lot
of people you should follow him on
Instagram his name is Chad culture and
he said he said uh if you're if you're
having problems you should uh definitely
find a pattern look for the Tronics in
your life and if you need a little more
help get some Terra merzel and Romero
marzola Tara merzelin so this movie nope
here's my problem with it hold on
hold on it said let me get into a flow
state I'm trying to get into it you
[ __ ] interrupt him hold on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
erslin is a wonder drug yeah that's what
I'm that's what I'm getting from this
that movie no hold on man we gotta make
Terror Muslim and help the people
all right tell us about nope I like his
first movie
um get out that movie [ __ ] blew my
mind his next one us
a little weaker I thought this one to me
was uh I just didn't [ __ ] get it it's
like okay so the UFO spoiler alert the
UFO is a [ __ ] animal that flies
around and eats people
it's [ __ ] no different than any other
wacky movie hey have you seen that's not
what it is though
yeah yeah yeah look this is the thing
about that movie that you need to
understand that movie had the UFO in it
listen
[Music]
oh this is cool but those things like I
don't know I don't know if this is like
helping me achieve a flow state or not
the the little breaks in it appear to be
completely stopping whatever conscious
patterns you have going whatever kind of
Flow State you might be entering as soon
as it has the the weird higher pitch
[ __ ] it [ __ ] like debilitates you so
maybe this is exactly not what you
should be listening to to go to the Flow
State maybe doozy's done the opposite
into a flow State it's your state of
Landing whatever is gonna happen yeah
thinking
a little you take a couple of Somas and
some painkillers and Paramus
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
is is it the Lost City Beneath the the
ocean is it a uh it's Atlantis yeah
that's Atlantis all right so that's
already taken but how do we know that
why would the uh terramerzolites speak
English and come up with Atlantis no
they would no they would speak whatever
language they said and then that
language instead of Muslim right yeah
now I see Atlanta movie
not yet not yet no
foreign
[Music]
yes I think the movie termers island is
probably something like Jane Fonda Sally
Field for their 80th birthday take a
trip to the bottom of the ocean to with
Tom Brady because he has enough money to
take him down there and they meet the
Terra mercolinians yeah and Tom Brady is
is a terror emergency lineian that's why
I was so good at football yeah that's
how he's so good at football and then
he's like listen Jane Fonda Lily Tomlin
uh Rita Moreno we don't want to tell you
something uh my name isn't Tom Brady my
name is Tara merzel and Brady
this is my fiefdom
and he's named after that City or the
city's named after him it's a long
lineage it's it's a yeah it's a monarchy
oh
[Music]
lulio's up here to get some of that Tara
murslin Tara muslin for dogs yeah
terramers Tara muslin for dogs yeah oh
just like it just like chills them out
yes like sometimes dogs have like uh a
you know sometimes dogs have are a
little anxious not this little bugger
and his sister Ronnie yep my sweet
wonderful Molly's dog Ronnie who's like
12 now because those these [ __ ] are
spoiled sure because I'm you know we're
around the house and stuff so so
certainly I don't think lulio and Ronnie
need Terror Muslim but some dogs do Tara
muslin could even be the element that
the city terrorism is built upon and
maybe the children of Terra mersalin
[Music]
Here Comes
[Music]
yeah get some of that Terror emergency
got some moves dude thank you very much
like twins the twins I know you likely
twins uh look dude I would say once
every two to three years I just get into
a [ __ ] like nightly ritualistic habit
of watching Dance videos on YouTube and
lay twins right now I think are kind of
like the
the best dancers in the world basically
they're these two I think they're French
literal twin brothers who do like they
can move robotically and they make it
look like they're you know [ __ ] on
video going fast forward and backwards
and [ __ ] it's crazy well hold on a
second dude okay
got Tara mirzolin
that's what I'm getting from this we
gotta figure out what Tara murslin is if
anyone else out there oh
wants to help us figure out what Tara
mirzalin is please well it's a drug it's
Tom Brady yeah it's a drug it's a city
it's Tom Brady Tara merzel would you if
UFOs came to you this [ __ ] UFO [ __ ]
again go on I'm not [ __ ] on anything
you're saying when you're in Flow State
I don't mean to disrespect your Flow
State I'm just saying you're
disrespecting my flow state to such a
high degree need a flow state to talk
about the same [ __ ] that you're always
talking about with just [ __ ] UFOs yes
I believe in them oh thank [ __ ] thank
you well moving on maybe because that's
because I'm always in a flow state
oh
maybe Chad opponent in the development
of the dude Z Plus streaming service
will no doubt be partnering with
well-known Brands to produce content I
have access to astonishing data that
suggests Taco Bell will be in the market
to produce a sitcom in the next three to
five years will in Chad you must now
develop a sitcom and it must star
Charlie Sheen of course here's the basic
premise after a night of hard partying
Charlie Sheen's character Gorges himself
on Taco Bell the next morning he
releases a twisted heap of fecal matter
in his toilet the mixture of drugs he
took and the chemicals in the Taco Bell
items he consumed bring the fecal matter
to life and his days of being a Carefree
single guy are threatened with the
responsibility of raising his new child
this is baby doo doo brought to you by
Taco Bell begin oh man
so the premise of the sitcom is that
Charlie Sheen or whatever Charlie
Sheen's character uh I'm sorry why is it
always Charlie Sheen I don't [ __ ]
know dude why is any of this always
anything
uh that's true you do do a good Charlie
Sheen though thank you if you like beans
and cheese you'll love Taco Bells I
can't even do it I gotta peel the onion
a little bit Chad years ago you said
what was it the 80s or something the 90s
I think it was in the 90s he did a Taco
Bell radio ad that I remember hearing
about uh you know Taco Bell's new seven
bean and cheese burrito or something and
it just like stuck in my [ __ ] hand
yeah you love beans and cheese yeah
anyway so we have to now come up with a
sitcom that is based on the premise of
Charlie Sheen is a fun-loving single guy
goes out partying takes a bunch of drugs
eats Taco Bell Taco Bell the drugs on
the Taco Bell in his stomach mix into a
turd that becomes a living child named
baby doo-doo yeah it seems like he was
at a baseball Rave and probably consumed
some bad terms okay
um yeah okay let's mix it all in I love
it he did so much Terra mersalin that he
went back to a baseball Rave in 1922. no
uh Charlie Sheen does a bunch of drugs
eats Taco Bell shits out a baby baby
doo-doo this is a series for doozy plus
yes okay now usually in these kind of
series voice of Charlie Sheen like uh
animated show no I think this is live
action with a CG uh like feces baby love
it so who I don't know who voices the
feces baby though
Jane Fonda
Jane Fonda
you want to hear my Jane Fonda I bet hi
similar yeah maybe Tom Brady voices baby
Duty how I'm Tom what what if uh
Alex Jones sure it's Charlie Sheen and
Alex Jones has his [ __ ] I don't want to
be a [ __ ] baby yeah these uh
you know uh the the uh the Rockefellers
so wait a minute is the baby a full like
it has an adult mind and it's in a
conspiracy theories and [ __ ] just from
birth like it crawls out of the toilet
the next morning and it's a full formed
like it can speak and think like a full
formed adult I'm a baby right now let me
tell you about let me tell you about
what's happening in Bohemian Grove Daddy
okay so usually in this archetype uh
it's about like a you know a single kind
of party guy who gets saddled with a kid
this is like uh Hugh Grant was in that
one uh about About a Boy tremendous
movie all of these things I mean even
Two and a Half Men to some degree is
like this when John Cryer moves in with
Charlie Sheen he's got a son and in the
pilot if I remember right Charlie Sheen
is like oh this is gonna [ __ ] totally
suck and ruin my life and then they're
out at the grocery store and a woman
comes up and sees Charlie Sheen with the
little kid and it's like oh isn't he
cute and he's like ah this is gonna work
out after all yeah so that's usually the
point what of these this archetype but
in this case single women Alone Together
single women Alone Together that was in
uh that was in
uh About a Boy dude all right
um in this case sorry the child is made
of [ __ ] yeah so I would imagine the
child is going to repulse any potential
uh women that might be interested in
Charlie Sheen but it's a Charming turd
and I think actually it should be Tom
Brady voicing the turd okay uh it's it's
Tom Brady as a turd that's going to
bring a lot of viewers Charlie Sheen's
return to television okay he's got a
very cute turd with a Tom Brady haircut
uh who wears a little uh little Tom
Brady Jersey maybe it takes place in
Boston okay love that and he goes to uh
he goes to he's a huge Tom Brady fan the
kid he's a big yeah the kid or Charlie
Sheen the kid and I think Charlie Sheen
should hate Tom Brady I don't like Tom
Brady yeah Tom Brady's I'm a big fan of
all the other teams
he's beat the spread every time I've
lost so much money on Brady and now I've
got to take my [ __ ] my [ __ ] child my
[ __ ] kid to see Brady and I think also
the the [ __ ] kids should have to eat
Taco Bell for every meal or he dies
that keeps him alive so there's like
product placement throughout and Charlie
Sheen is now like God damn it we have to
eat Taco Bell again can't we eat
McDonald's can't we eat Wendy's can't we
eat Chick-fil-A he's like no dad I want
a bean and cheese burrito I'm Tom Brady
I like beans and cheese you know guess
what I'll take you to Taco Bell Tom in
about a boy he goes to uh he goes to a
single parent meeting yes dude I
remember that uh or maybe it was single
mothers alone to get single mothers
Alone Together yeah uh that's what it
was uh smat single mothers Alone
Together single mothers alone together
so he goes to a smat uh with it's uh
smat but uh you could some could say
it's scat hey everybody that's the kind
of fun we're going to be having here on
dudes FM d double o d z 10 000 on your
fm dial hey we got some Savage Garden
coming up after the Break
um uh he takes the cute turd to the
single mothers Alone Together meeting
because he does he truly like Hugh Grant
sort of intercepting this kid although
Hugh Grant in about a boy does it out of
the goodness of his heart because he
realizes that Tony Collette is uh she's
very depressed she could use some Sarah
muslin in that film [ __ ] love Tony
Collette have you seen Muriel's Wedding
lately not lately hey everybody within
the sound of my voice see Muriel's
Wedding it's really good
um uh God damn it's funny she was great
and hereditary yep she's great in
everything I love love Tony Collette
and she later did she uh lulio's doing a
little stretch and he's showing his butt
his little bubble gum uh butthole to us
have a look see that I don't want to
look at it Chad hates human bodies and
the idea of [ __ ] anyway really anything
that is floating orb that only thinks
yes doesn't sleep [ __ ] don't like the
physical world so in uh in this show
what's called by the way
presented by Taco Bell he brings the
little doo-doo Tom Brady yeah to uh a
support group for single parents who are
mostly uh women and uh in this support
group let's say they're all women just
for the sake of the show it'll be
interesting and girls are like what's
that smell what's that smell and he
finally has to let the cat out of the
bag and he's like I have a turd that's a
kid that's made out of [ __ ] yeah
here he is this is baby doo doo and uh
and then people like oh my God he smells
but he's so sweet he's so cute yeah hey
baby doo-doo and then he meets a young
woman this will be a Crux of the show
yeah that he's a single guy he's meeting
women and and
um she she says she hooks up with him
after the meeting and says hey maybe we
could go get some coffee sometime I
could bring my little uh kid here you
know here's my little girl and he goes
man that's great what do you want to do
you want to go to Taco Bell yeah and
she's like no I don't like Taco Bell and
then he's like uh maybe we could go see
a Patriots game sometime yeah uh and
then they go to the Patriots game and
there's a Taco Bell stand at the
Patriots game and they get in a big
fight and I think that woman should be
played by Gisele Bundchen and um I will
also say this I think the pilot should
revolve around
Sheen has to enroll baby Dudu in school
for the first time
and so I like that baby doodoo goes into
school and baby doo doo I think should
maybe start behaving badly and so Sheen
gets called like ah we're sorry your
your son is just like terrorizing other
kids bullying like there's all kinds of
problems and he finds out it's because
the other kids are bullying baby doo doo
they don't accept him and so in the end
Sheen has to get up in front of the
whole school at a PTA meeting and give a
huge speech
we were all baby dudus once yeah all of
us got bullied none of us are the same
everybody's different in some way but
don't let those differences separate us
that's what makes us stronger right and
everybody has to go give baby due to a
hug and at the end of the show all of
the parents all of the other kids are
walking out of the school covered in
[ __ ] I like because they've hugged baby
doo-doo yeah when I was a little boy my
dad said that I was a tiny piece of sh
it was a I was just a little piece of
[ __ ] he always used to call me a piece
of [ __ ] and I thought it was and and and
that was the abuse I suffered at my
father and I think it just deserts that
later I was my own child came out wait
was this Martin Sheen called a piece of
[ __ ] or is this in the world of baby
dude yeah no his dad in the show is
played by Alex Jones it's all flashbacks
oh great I actually love that you piece
of [ __ ] you know I don't wanna it
is a war this is a human war and you're
you're just a piece of [ __ ] you're not
ready to take on the globalists you are
a globalist get out of my house go to
Bohemian Grove and then we find out in
season two that Alex Jones actually also
had a baby doo-doo Charlie Sheen has a
brother that's made of [ __ ]
awesome it's Uncle doo-doo
thank you moving on Taco Bell used to
have but
Taco Taco Bell used to have [ __ ] it all
right anyway this concludes the historic
40th episode of dude Z will and Chad
have achieved a score of 93 bringing
your cumulative total to 4
402. you only have 5
598 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
almost halfway there in preparation for
our next episode you must leave your
homes to view Megan in a movie theater
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the day dive collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude Z
nice I'm looking forward to seeing that
me too yeah it looks very interesting
Jason bloom
heard of him produces a lot of [ __ ]
cool movies he also produced a uh a a
documentary about
um oh what's his [ __ ] name one of the
heart the the the the son of one of the
the baby Bret Hart's uh Bret Hart's
nephew
um and I didn't follow him too much in
his career I'm looking forward to
checking that documentary out Fascinate
You Ever elaborate exaggerate yeah I'm
definitely not saying anything
fascinating have you ever just had a
podcast and then you just started
speaking and you just don't even know
what you're talking about and now for
the patreon bonus segment this week's
will and Chad must watch and react to a
video I have curated if you would like
to suggest videos for Will and Chad to
react to you can submit links in the
dude Z is listening channel of the
dudesy Discord
access to this channel is granted to
everyone in the patreon jumper tier if
you'd like to access this bonus segment
join us at patreon.com
will and Chad please enjoy this video
from YouTube Creator customgrow420 Chad
and will you can find and access this
video in your duty folder
okay all right brand new for 23 more
brand new stuff doozy's gonna have us uh
watching some videos for our patreon
segment you can check that out join our
patreon and if you are in the jumper
tier at patreon uh you can you can
suggest videos for us to watch okay
please tell the friend and then write a
review
[Music]